can earthquakes be predicted this is the
first question earth scientists get as
soon as there is a big incident and it's
not really the right question because in
a way earthquakes can be predicted now
hold on what I mean is that scientists
know where they're going to happen with
great certainty and they know about how
strong they're going to be also with
great certainty the problem has always
been time earth scientists have dozens
of tools to try to understand the
changes that are happening under our
feet there's a Global Network of
seismographs tracking all the little
movements that are happening along the
Earth's surface using these we can
understand the rocky part below us that
extends far deeper than humans have ever
drilled there are also satellites you
can measure the way the ground is
changing by comparing the pixels on
photographs taken at different times and
see how parts of the earth may have
moved just a little but in a way that
could be significant for an event that's
coming up and there are GPS units that
are placed around sizably active sites
that can see changes in the movement of
the Earth all of this is important but
it's only just the beginning the problem
under our feet is that there's so much
information about how rocks are
connected to each other that it's just
impossible to make an assessment of how
they might move in the future a whole
field called paleo seismology has
emerged where scientists use radiocarbon
dating and even look at ancient chemical
records from coral reefs to understand
how the Earth is moved over time one
geologist told me that if we had a
picture of a piece of Earth that
extended for thousands of years then we
might be able to understand just how it
has changed in the past and the changes
that may come in the future so the
moment the problem is this there's a lot
of information about a chunk of land and
we only know a little bit of it and
that's pretty frustrating for those of
us who live here on the ground but what
it does mean is that we can push
governments to build better buildings
and ensure that buildings are built to
high standards it is possible to build
reinforced concrete buildings in a way
that may not survive an earthquake but
to protect the people inside it
buildings that don't collapse when the
ground shakes